all right look boulet kev podcast we got
a legend
about to roll up some og yeah
dame dash it's popping what's up man
appreciate you sitting down bro i mean i
came through to my spot hey let me yeah
i i feel like it's a real inspiring
space too i got to kind of just see you
uh rehearsing with your band um
just tell tell me about game dash
studios where we are
you know i saw you in there jamming out
with the band shout out to the homie
alien your drummer who i've known for a
long time
um
well really this is like a spaceship
and we like time travel
you know
and it's a place where like you know
anything that inspires us we just do
you know i mean so it's music movies
it's books it's
cartoons education it's you know i'm a
television network yeah but the
programmings are things that inspire me
you know whatever i'm feeling i got to
do
and i feel like that's the magic you
know that's the trick
you know that's the goal to be able to
monetize things that you would do for
free
so we're just hanging out that's
everyone's goal in life i feel like
right now how to make money
we're not really meant to work our whole
life
or you know that's a slave mentality
we're meant to [ __ ] party and have
fun our whole life right right but you
got to figure out what is a healthy
party
you know what's a sustainable party
how can you feed your family off of
like why do you have any things you
don't like to feed your family fact why
do you have to be separated from your
family to feed your family
you know what i mean why do you have to
do it in times that your family would be
spending with you
like when the sun's out right the sun's
not out my son sleep my baby's sleep yep
so he ain't missing any dreaming and
that's some real [ __ ] like the time you
would actually want to spend with your
kids is during the day but then you if
you if you have a nine to five
well you're behind a desk but where's
your kid behind a desk
eight hours a day
it's just training him to [ __ ] be all
right we're sitting behind a desk when
the sun's up we should be in the [ __ ]
ocean looking at some water
running around in the garden or
something you know what's crazy is i
gotta give you props man cause um you
had that breakfast club interview a few
years ago where you talked about
ownership
and that [ __ ] really like resonated with
me
so that was that was my purpose i wanted
it to resonate yeah man cause you know
like
i've done radio for so long and
have worked for
you know the ihearts the
conglomerates of the of the radio
industry
and uh at the end of last year i walked
away from like terrestrial radio in a
sense of working for anybody and just
starting my own syndicated radio show
starting my own podcast and now i'm on
hella markets and all those companies
like i heart you know like i'm a partner
and you own it right i own it uh you
know what i'm saying like i still and
i'm still on reel 92 3 in la but i'm on
real 92 3 in la every night on my own
terms and it promotes everything you're
doing that you own 100
and i don't i don't i don't work for
them you know what i'm saying i used to
work for iheart you know i mean my
checks used to say iheart media
and and you know i kind of
feel like like
that interview you did man was a lot of
inspiration for me so i just want to
give you props man because that's some
real [ __ ] like you can't really say
you're a boss
unless you're really a boss unless
you're actually about unless you
actually have employees you know what
i'm saying you should pay somebody
unless you actually have a business
unless you lose the money to make money
unless you know unless you're taking
that risk that gamble this is yours you
know unless you're a founder something
that came from your brain yeah you know
something that inspires you and that you
stood behind fearlessly now i've been
seeing you in there um jamming out with
your band bro and um kind of talk about
what blue rock is because i saw i i saw
that that's something
obviously for people who don't know man
blackrock was an incredible body of work
that you put out over what was that
2006-7
[Music]
yeah first time i ever heard the black
keys was on that album yeah um
i feel like that album doesn't get
talked about enough
you know probably by people that
wouldn't appreciate it you know right
those kind of things
to me it's like drugs you know you don't
advertise them you're just word of mouth
it's so good people who it's like if you
know you know type [ __ ] right that's the
way i like it yeah for me it's not about
pop culture it's about people that are
like-minded
it's about a code an ethic where we're
speaking in a room saying there's
something and no one else understands
right because we're talking in the boss
well everybody else is talking is slave
some real [ __ ] you'd be having a
conversation in a room full of 30 people
and only two people are on the same
wavelength
it'd be rare that i'd even have that
conversation and let myself be in that
situation i've actually been able to
architect where i don't have to be
around morons anymore
that's a beautiful thing bubble you know
it's a beautiful thing you i feel like
too you kind of have had a lot of um
a big hand in um in bringing
the black keys kind of to like the
forefront of like no no no no i broke
the black keys there's no doubt about it
no one knew who they was they didn't
even do videos that's what i'm saying
they didn't make videos they didn't even
know what it was like to actually have
brett
or what it looked like to spend it
i burnt them out
and now they're one of the biggest rock
groups in the world
so yeah but you know my beef with them
is that they never ever showed the
appreciation to those artists that broke
them which was hip-hop and everything
jones the most devs
those guys didn't even know who they
were they did it just because they
trusted me then all of a sudden they
blew up and they were like yo
they were
gone their ideals changed
that's how i looked at it pat mccartney
was very disappointing
to me wow and you know tell them i said
so well we got to give you your flowers
in the rock world too man you know what
i'm saying shout out to dame dash we
gotta uh
because i'm a fan of of of of of of that
uh i appreciate leg of of of what you
did man and what you continue to work
there's a black rock too that's what i'm
saying you were telling me about that
yeah but those guys went missing they
didn't want to put it out and i didn't
feel like chasing them to put it up
mm-hmm but it has sean price on it talib
khali
you know where's khalifa [ __ ]
currency
before black and yellow
where's khalifa
what is what is blue rock blue rock is
my music division within my media empire
it's where it's really my therapy
like i do music for fun
i'm gonna monetize it don't get it
twisted
but it's not urgent to me to monetize
it's not about when it's like i'm
building a catalog of things that will
be considered vinyl
for people that appreciate real music
and instrumentation and just like
you know the effort it takes you know it
took us two days to set the room up just
to record because it's an art
if you look at what they're doing
they're recording in different rooms
they're recording live
it's an art
you know yeah i was watching this
documentary on netflix you know on
disney plus about the beatles and
they're doing exactly what i've been
doing i'm like the beatles been copying
me
that's how i felt
you know
that's fair man um i definitely think
you know
you've laid a lot of the groundwork for
a lot of the stuff that's popping right
now so you know well i thought the
biggest compliment that kanye gave me
was the original black hipster
the original black hipster yeah cause i
feel like that's what every kid wants to
be and i really i guess if kanye said it
if kanye said it right who who we kind
of look as the guy who brought wearing
pink polos to hip hop and
you know
kind of normalizing like
certain aspects of fashion and music if
he said it then well he made it
everything
that's unnormal to be normal
yeah i mean i feel like that drink
champs interview obviously was uh a
moment that would hip-hop
for hip-hop that will live on forever um
all our interviews are anybody in my
bloodline
interview is classic
um but what what kanye said about you
essentially being the architect being
the visionary um i mean i remember as a
kid seeing you on backstage
and being like man this guy's this guy's
the that's that's the ceo right i
remember you yelling at dj clue for
wearing the def jam leather jacket
and just being like man like i i [ __ ] i
[ __ ] with that
just that mindset they're like yo no
we're rockefeller like
yeah they they made it easy for me to be
me
you know
i like being batman
the villains are people that are doing
wrong but a hero to those that need to
be protected
our culture
so you know they were a lot of fun to me
making examples you notice i taped all
that [ __ ] you saw it because i captured
it yeah i just want y'all to see that
you know that's how i treat them sucker
[ __ ]
and y'all could treat them the same way
too
that's why i showed it and captured it i
want you to see the truth
they make you believe that there's
something they're not and that you need
them and you don't and behind closed
doors certain people kiss ass and
certain people make them kiss the ring
i make them kiss the ring or that make
them bend the knee i'll break their back
till they bend the knee
and i think that that is something that
can be applied
self-awareness of who you are and what
our culture represents yeah we're the
jewel of the universe
and the only way to control the jewels
that make the jewel think that the jewel
is not the jew
i'm not going for that dumb [ __ ] i know
i'm the jew i shine
and my culture shines
i think that that has kind of been the
blueprint of the music industry right
making artists think
that they need the label culture make us
fight each other
and [ __ ] protect our oppressor like
they [ __ ] ought to plug it's a good
program
you know
kudos to the enemy
but once we're aware of it why keep
letting them winning that way knowing
that it's just a mental thing physically
we kick ass and mentally too we just
have to know it
and it takes it takes like i feel like
finally it takes doing it i feel like
finally there's like a new generation of
artists that you know the kids just
listening
that's what i was investing in the first
place yeah i was like these old
[ __ ] do not listen they're just
stubborn
they're complacent they just want to
survive
get the next advance check
survive never recoup and be depressed
and then be like what the [ __ ] i don't
consider that living yeah i feel like
there this
finally this
era of artists at least it seems like a
young a lot of these younger kids well
you see our revolutions are yeah
they do
but we do have to stop glorifying us
killing each other
because that's just them celebrating
that's a w every time
one of us gets hurt and it starts doing
it to each other every time us doing it
to each other and then the suicide
mission the bad food we keep putting in
our body
like how are you going to trust your
pressure oppressor to feed you
he's pissing on your food bro
i would never let my enemy feed me that
doesn't make sense
it's not logical
i never let the person that's knocking
me down give me food religion or
anything i'm not listening to nothing
you saying because it's only to control
me
i'm aware of that
i think we all are but everybody's [ __ ]
that's the problem
fear is implemented it's a program to
stop us from making our dreams come true
and most of the things we're scared of
never happened
until you think about it so much that
you manifested
you know when you're sitting around
thinking about [ __ ] you're scared of
that means you're not doing nothing
about it because when you're doing [ __ ]
you ain't thinking about the past you're
thinking about what's in front of you
you know so if you got time to reflect
that's too much time you should be
working
too much time reflecting and sucking
[ __ ] to me
that's licking your wounds
i rather fight
and that's what i want to be famous for
fighting i don't want to be famous for
rapping
i want to be famous for acting
i want to be famous for kicking some
[ __ ] ass to those that deserve it and
helping people that i love
and that's what i'm gonna go down in
history for
an ass kicker
fear is definitely the one thing right
that keeps everybody in their place you
know what i'm saying we think of people
who
won't take that risk to start their own
business or
we're telling my artist earlier but
don't even tell the truth you know i did
an experiment last week
because i was like i don't understand
how people are depressed it's so much
fun to be healthy
and i was like there were some things
that were bothering me with people that
were close to me and i said i'm not
going to talk about what's bothering me
for until at least they talk about it
and they didn't talk about it
and i internalized it and i was sad a
little bit every day because of that and
i was like [ __ ] this is what the
pressure is
i'm never doing that again so
i dealt with it i articulated in a
different way because the only way to
change
a scenario is to do it different
you know the thing about people is
they'd be like oh why is it always
happening this way because you [ __ ]
do it the same way every day right you
react the same way
you move the same i mean how do you
expect a different result if you're not
doing anything different
you know so i decided to approach it a
different way
and i wrote like letters and [ __ ] and
then it worked itself out by the end of
the day what i know is i'm never gonna
ever let anything that's bothering me
faster faster because that causes
sadness which causes cancer it's not
healthy to be unhappy
laughter is key as well
laughter is key man i feel like yeah i
mean just being here for the last few
hours i feel like you you kind of have a
great environment for creatives here for
just
nothing it's a vibe in here man this is
what this is you know sometimes you got
to machiavelli yourself for peace
and i needed people to leave me to [ __ ]
along so i could actually work on me
and architect the environment that i
could do daily to the extent that i
don't even see time
i can't i'm like 50 and i'm like what
the [ __ ] how'd that happen i don't feel
50.
i don't feel i might have so much fun
it's more fun than when i was 20. wow
it's crazy it says a lot man that's why
people should invest in their future see
when i was 25 i looked at what i wanted
to be doing in 25 years i was like i'm
definitely not going to be trying to
shake a [ __ ] bottle on the stage
you know i did that
right of course of course
i just saw you reenact the uh the dame
dash dance from that's the only way it
was happening bro i just saw that i was
like yo you nailed it like and then i
just saw it i'm not i know it's your
[ __ ] but i was like
you'd have thought it was it was it was
99 or 2000 again it's my days if i ever
can't do my own dance that's real [ __ ]
up
and it's it's like it's like it's it's
as much of a dance as it's just like a
moment it's like it's like a lot of
moments bro if you notice it was like
it's the dame dash dance is like 30
different dances every time i [ __ ]
danced in a video and it got captured it
was just
you know
me being free how was what freedom looks
like that dance
how was it you know what's really funny
when people try to do it looks simple
but you just can't do it that doesn't
look simple to me a little kickback and
all that i've been like it's simple to
me a little spin down to the floor the
spin to the floor is doing this move
it's like a hand mixtape move on the
floor with a box i can't do it any time
i don't know
uh
i obviously you know but i do it when i
perform
yeah i was gonna say like you know you
you were in there jamming out and you
have a you have a full do you have a
full band you're singing like i got to
hear some music um
you know
yeah like like is that something i mean
obviously you're going to monetize
whatever you do right but like you said
music
it's just therapeutic for you as well
right you know what happens um is
usually what what how it started was
coming for a second son hassan was
coming around and doing artistic things
and i was like i don't give a [ __ ] if
your show's not right
it doesn't matter so i was like hassan
your live show be a real artist and go
get yourself a band
and you got a band they were all right
but you know i was starting to rehearse
them to show them how to do it
and then i ended up firing all of them
and [ __ ] but you know and it just turned
into me just [ __ ]
making just as many songs it's like a
competition matter of fact
i'm gonna let him tell you just say it
real quick okay so what happened with
the blue rock boot campers and walking
through it he's been in boot camp for
three [ __ ] years
so the blue rock boot camp is something
that is it's all documented just tell
them
what are you required what are you
required to do man give us the rundown
you're definitely gonna you're
definitely gonna if you have fear
he's gonna
he's gonna mirror whatever you have in
you and you're gonna have to overcome
that
and it's amazing because it's like on
some real like karate kid master
splinter that's what it sounds like it
sounds deep because i realized how much
anger i had
and
and uh
and it was so funny because there was
moments where i was like
seeing that mirror and you overcome that
and then you you have love you have no
choice but to have love after that
because the fear is hatred so we have to
understand that anyone who does have
fear it has hatred and if you have
hatred you can't have love but
yeah so what we when we were doing that
and then it became like every night it
was like he'd go do a song that he'd be
like and then i'll go do a song and then
we go back and forth and it was like
he'll be like i'm calling you out yeah
be like i'm going for the song with you
performing wise yes
in the street whatever i'm never gonna
send somebody to do something i gonna do
myself that's some real [ __ ] that's how
everybody should be if i'm up there
doing it then you better be doing it at
least as good as me or better or way
better yeah yeah
yeah right right right
that's some real [ __ ] and the whole
process is gonna be
you know every step of it he's gonna be
there and he's gonna you know if you if
you're gonna like he always says you
ain't gonna hustle me yeah so if you
show up and you do it like he's going to
be there and he's going to be like oh
this is you know
hey man wait it's not only the
performance what else you got to come
with
you got to come with the visuals you got
to come with the i i didn't i got a
whole tv show now it's a whole entourage
kirby enthusiasm
oh
wow
i don't you can't be performing what
happens is every two every
a certain day
i let all the artists that i know
come through when i have the band and
they gotta perform but you can't just
perform you got to come and bring a
visual there's a screen you got to bring
the experience
you know what i mean like you know so i
was shooting shoot and edited everything
for real
hey for real like i think that that's
that's something like like like we
talked about earlier like
that might be one of the only things
from the older
era of music
development of artists development of
that that you know current season
100 courtesy of that rock chain on for
sure um where's khalifa
jay electronic yeah
all of them were in dd172
i made all of them practice you
understand what i'm saying
um style
shout out to staley crick
chris one of the best chris one of the
best live performers in the world we we
did their first videos yeah the first i
have all their live first performance
sleigh bell did their first show slay
those did their first show on my
basement wow
yeah and it's well documented
that's big you know i mean but you can't
come to me and tell me you got a good
record if you ain't got a good show
yeah the live shows is also i need to
see you that's important i want to see
basically the wait tell them how you got
in the in the loop in the first place
right so uh
me and his son we're cool and your son
has a cookie company right i was back
okay
and basically that's the one basically
there was a closing factor that we were
making i was making merch out of right
and then i showed his son and we yeah it
got to him man wow yeah no no but how
did i let you start to be creative in
here oh
because
so i had just did a publishing deal
right so i i'm a producer yeah and i was
like yo i don't want to email beats no
more
because i think it's disrespectful as
like yo send me a pack you know it's
like yeah you respect the creative you
want in the studio yeah
exactly so i was like man i don't want
to email beats no more
and i want to do a beat gallery
so uh in here we i had visuals and each
beat had a color that was back when i
had the other side before colbert it
wasn't yeah it was like a huge thing
yeah and and i put qr codes on the wall
so if someone liked it they could they
could scan their phone on the qr code
david sebastian
shout out david sebastian man that's the
homie and when you scared i knew him as
an artist before saying yep yep yep and
when you scan the qr code you got sent
the stems to the beat directly to your
phone with no email wow so it was like
this whole steve jobs presentation or
whatever
yeah anyway that's what happened he did
something creative that i liked and i
was very creative and you bought people
and you bought culture you can [ __ ]
do some [ __ ] and i just want to add to
those lists and now hassan and i will be
the biggest there we are hey hey
representing saint pete yeah saint pete
727 man yeah
that's my guy bro the bootleg the
bootleg head podcast presented by odd
socks
those are my boys we're just in miami
with the odd socks guys man yeah shout
out hey man that's a beautiful situation
um
dame i want to talk to you man like
you know obviously
we talked about this drink champs
interview and and you know you've you
and kanye have been locked in uh forever
but uh i feel like
you've been real close to him in in in
you know some rough times for him maybe
perceived by the public at least you
know he's been going through a lot of
personal [ __ ] with his family and stuff
but i i know you've been spending a lot
of time with yay and um
even just like being out in wyoming a
lot like
do you feel like you and kanye have
gotten closer than ever
in the last couple of years because it
feels that way
i don't really talk about that part
you know
he's an interesting guy and you know our
relationship when he speaks on it i'm
surprised
but
you know i don't really do that
you know what i mean that's fair
disrespect for him
plus you know i don't want to trigger
him
that's some real [ __ ] man that's some
real [ __ ]
i wanted you offline i could show you
some questions yeah um
i remember
i bought the double disc
paid in full
dream team album as a kid from the
warehouse
and i threw in that dream team disc and
we are the champions was the first
record on there right
it's
one of the most like iconic like un
under-appreciated historical moments in
hip-hop because that was really when we
heard yay before we knew who the [ __ ] he
was
i mean people you know the thing about
that was
it was uh
the reason for is uh what i will say
about kanye is he's the only one
on a real level that's giving me a
certain kind of respect
the only one and it doesn't matter
because he's the biggest one right he's
the only being near the whole crew
it's funny you know but he's the only
one that's paid proper respect and he's
always been that guy
and what happened was i had asked jess
blaze to flip that beat for me and just
blaze did not and i was aggravated about
it like i yelled at him about it
probably because i found it
disrespectful like i send an order and
you [ __ ] don't prioritize it
and i asked kanye to do what he did at
that day
at night and you know history was made
and it was just because of the respect
that he gave me
is the reason why i was so successful
was the record that the first record he
got played on the record on the radio as
a rapper
yeah it can't you know it was good i
mean in fact that was the first moment
we knew it was the first time queen had
actually cleared a sample they cleared
it for me
and i feel like it was the first time we
heard
twista officially repping that rock
yeah
he always considered my brother him and
raw
those are my brothers you know i
remember like because i was trying to do
like a hostile takeover
i was taking um
common sense i had tyler
john legend it was like crazy but like
craig coleman was giving me an issue
when he was at the at a show
and i was like yo why are you going to
just let the twisted you know he was
being a sucker about it so i got on the
stage and i just gave him my rock chain
it was like he's with us anyway [ __ ]
you yeah cause twister never actually
signed with rockefeller right now it was
just fantastic it was fantastic
there's no sign you family fans so you
were you were trying to also joe buttons
were signing me and so was not signing
me was on rockefeller and so was nori no
one even talks about that i remember
nori being on rockefeller yeah but joe
buttons was true i didn't know joe was
yeah he doesn't talk about it i was uh
i i didn't but normie angel buttons
don't pass plugs for the record
you were chosen by [ __ ] but past the
plug during that time you were um
you were also trying to
bring common and talib over you were
saying yeah ask them
that's crazy yeah kanye you know this is
different it's a young it's a whole as
kanye but you know those are
those are funny stories you know you got
to think like remember i was a guy that
was touring kanye but i was also having
john legend tour with us
so i you know i laid that foundation i
thought he was signing with us he didn't
i was like
that was some [ __ ] but
you'd be surprised how many careers i
launched on the low
i mean
we talked about the black keys earlier
we can't let that go unsaid
but i was talking about like crit no no
no for yo
the big credit cards like a whisper you
know not to say i want because i you
know
just
just how many people that i was like
actually advising just for free
just i wouldn't sign that's the thing
they all wanted me to sign them i just
wouldn't
it wasn't like they didn't want to sign
i was dame dash i had an art gap my
office the funny [ __ ] was when i walked
out of the music business and everyone
was broke i had like a three-story
building in tribeca doing the illest
coolest [ __ ]
it was so funny to me that's why i was
like oh
i would never expect my oppressor to
celebrate my independence
so if i'm 50 now and they still be
[ __ ] with me i'd be like wow i must
really be a threat
because i haven't even come outside and
they still be like nah nah he can't look
like he wouldn't i don't care what it
looked like [ __ ]
it is what it is
like you know
if this is losing looks like [ __ ] it you
know what i'm saying that's what it is
wait hold on time to stop the interview
because we got to talk about our good
folks at odd socks man listen if you go
to
oddssocksofficial.com that's
oddsoxofficial.com
use the keyword keyword it's a [ __ ]
promo code use the [ __ ] promo code
bootleg kev all right at checkout you'll
save 20 off they got i mean look at
these spongebob joints
man the ninja turtle boys you know what
i'm saying how about the naruto guys
and then they got the new odd socks
basics that are just like
they're just so fly man the tie-dye
joints they just listen man
whatever you need they got it how about
some half-baked boys you know what i'm
saying listen
the most comfortable socks the most
affordable socks the best socks in the
world odd socks so go to odd
socksofficial.com
use that keyword it's not a keyword it's
a [ __ ] promo code
[ __ ]
bootleg cab at checkout save 20 off man
shout out to our family at odd socks if
you support us go support them uh hey
you talked earlier about asking uh just
to flip that sample initially right and
then do it connie ended up doing it
obviously just always had like a
snapping kind of thing shout out to jess
he's my brother but i'll be heating him
up i'm just curious like what what you
know you were there during the blueprint
sessions like
i bought the beats that's why i was
gonna ask you like kanye kanye talking
about just kind of cop being a copycat i
don't get into that [ __ ] but you know i
just know that both just blaze and con
and kanye came through hip-hop and he
bought me both of these beats
the reason why i like what's going on is
because really what happened with kanye
was the first record
song single that came out on rockefeller
with a kanye beat the dream seagull is
the truth yeah so you know
that was like the beginning of it all
and then he had all this beat tape
and i just brought it to jay and i just
had this blank mega [ __ ] you know what i
mean
but it was hip-hop that brought those
two
and then the same exact time i remember
like it's hip-hop's quiet so he's not
the kind of he's like you have to like
trigger him to know what's going on with
him right and i remember just being like
yo what the [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying like it was like that with rock
the mic like right i was like what's the
state property records and [ __ ] and i
was like listen i was like hold on you
buck put this [ __ ] out i'm a director
put it up
you know he's just quiet
but he's a genius they're all geniuses
a hundred percent man what was um
you know what was it like to hear uh
hope give you some love you know during
his speech at the uh at the rocking at
the rock and roll hall of fame induction
induction obviously
it was great for the culture that's why
that's the way i looked at it was like
and that's the way we'll leave it
good for the culture always good for the
culture no beef with no other black men
especially in someone i used to hustle
with
you know so whatever promotes that
image i'm with it
there it is there it is man
what um
you know what's crazy is like
i know you were behind bringing
a lot of people don't remember odb
before he passed dirk mcgirt was on
rockefeller
talk about like mariah picked him up
from jail i just say talk about that
because i feel like that that's like a
part of like the rockefeller uh legacy
we don't hear a lot of because it kind
of was at the tail end of things like
right like when things started to kind
of get interesting but like you know how
i'd be so cloudy bro
i forgot about a lot of that [ __ ]
so much good [ __ ] is happening in the
future
you know like i said when you're having
fun you don't like hold on to certain
things in the past and [ __ ] unless
you're like trying to learn from them
and and i was talking about that
situation the other day with old dirty i
just remember when he died his family
just
you know i went to his mom's house
all his kids was there just they just
was dancing and it was so happy through
that pain
i learned so much from that
you know i think about the good part
what you can learn from dark i gotta
find the light
but it hurt me because he died on my
watch
and i tried everything i could do he was
the first one i lost on my watch
is there um
something like
you know was going through something
like that and watching kind of
the generation of uh artists that
i feel like we've lost more artists
recently than we've lost
in a very long time it feels like
you know we just lost just lost dolph um
obviously
king vaughn last year i mean we could go
on and on so many people are passing
like is there any anything you learned
from
just being a man in this industry and
just being a man in this world like like
dealing with the loss or just dealing
with like
you're 50 right we talk we talk that
[ __ ] always hurts bro yeah like i'm
saying like the problem is you just
don't be surprised but it hurts
and when you know a lot of people
everything that happens affects you
when you love a lot of people you get a
lot of hurt
and i'm a guy that likes to help people
so everyone like that i've tried to help
or people that i've tried to help not
everyone because i help a lot of people
but the people that i've helped that
have gotten killed
it hurts
you know it hurts i have to get therapy
every time
it never doesn't affect me
because therapy is something that
obviously
is that is that something that you know
i feel like is finally kind of starting
to become less of a stimulant but yeah
of course i made it cool so yeah i do
healing as gangster
you know our culture doesn't usually get
therapy
so the study of people doesn't come from
black people it comes from white people
so when the black person finally does
get therapy he's getting the medicine at
a white person he's not a black person
different kind of trauma
so we need to find people that speak in
our tongue
that can actually help us but it is cool
to have a
consulary you know someone just doesn't
have a dog in a fight that could tell
you things just based on statistics
it's a consultant for your life you know
if you think that's weak trying to make
yourself strong then you're just a
[ __ ] clown to me
walking around bleeding stitching [ __ ]
up and not healing it
just gonna continue to bleed you know
it's dumb and the thing about being
uncomfortable for me i don't like being
uncomfortable so i do anything i can not
to be uncomfortable as quickly as
possible
so something's bothering me
immediately i'm trying to figure out any
way i can not to be bothered anymore but
people would rather be bothered and not
deal with it i just don't logically get
that
you give me another drink please
you know if we can get two of those
that'd be
i'm on the shrooms with you i don't have
the alcohol though
they've hit too we're chilling right now
nah that that's some real [ __ ] like like
you said like uh
she's like uh i don't work for you yeah
we're gonna courteous though that's
nicely you know she she doesn't have to
but uh she might she might not now but
you saw her in the face she's like this
thing
um no but what you just said about uh
why people wouldn't want to
become unbothered if they're bothered by
something
it's pride
i think it's i think it's really pride
man you know what i'm saying like to
think that that's a waste of time yeah
that's not pride pride is when you fight
for something you love when you have
pride you deal with your problems
because you have so much pride
that you can't look weak
i have so much pride that if i know that
something is making me look weak and i
got to take care of and be lead by
example i must be able to say yo i'm
making them [ __ ] i'm a little weak here
let me watch me go make myself stronger
that's why i do public therapy
nobody's not weak you know experiences
are new you don't [ __ ] deal with them
for the first time the best
you know it's not a weakness to just do
something and try to be better at it or
architect it before it happens it's not
weakness
and whoever thinks it you need therapy
you know i'm saying if you don't get it
you know it's called the social disorder
if you don't have accountability for
your problems will never be fixed
that's some real [ __ ] that is some real
[ __ ]
with the dame dash studios and you know
producing so much content
um
again like we can go back to a tv show
of course
cool deal
but that's how easy it is when you're a
boss i think of like no contracts when
you want to shoot
there it is no the question is when you
want to shoot it
uh
i mean this let's talk soon you talking
now what's what's the tv show
it's your show bro
i'd have to really think i would want
the show to be really good you know like
he mentioned ever put out a show that's
not really no i know that's what i'm
saying like i really got to think about
it i'm thinking about it this was what i
call an experiment
what i just did was say let's do a show
when you thought about the reasons why
it might not work no i didn't i just i
said again you said what do i want to do
you doubt it it's those questions don't
come into my mind hmm your automatic
fingers have got to be good
of course it's going to be good that's
like getting in bed with a girl and
doubting that you're going to have good
sex this is true
i don't be like oh i got to be good i
get it it's gonna be good it's gonna be
good so then why would you say that
first that's fair so that's what i was
explaining and i was truthful we're
gonna do a deal
but why do people
automatically think like that even good
people that are doing it right it's
still hard not to think about that first
and that's like what could go wrong you
think about that first as opposed to go
wrong i'm a [ __ ] don right i'm just
gonna fight
[Music]
i'm with it
but i was gonna say like uh
i mean talk about
the what was the first movie that you
produced
i forgot about what's been so many
obviously this is painful paid in full
yeah
but actually i did i think i feel like i
did street just watching was it what was
it wasn't there one um what was the
comedy um
paper planes paper soldiers paper
soldiers that's when i discovered kevin
hart kevin hart i was gonna say kevin
hart was in paper soldiers right yeah
which is crazy right because that was
before soul plane that was like [ __ ] i
took him off a stage and put him in his
first two three movies
what was it like
i i'm used to making people famous bro
i mean this is fair surprise i was gonna
say that i look at is how people act
after that's really what i like to look
at that's my if you notice i like to
experiment
life is i'm having so much fun in life
that i could [ __ ] play games and you
know
it's like surfing to me now thank you
yeah literally i was like okay let me
see if i could do this with my my arm
time behind my back there that's how i
thank you thank you look what the whole
world watching you know the difference
between me and everyone else is
i'm so confident about my fight that i
tell around
live
just because i know i'm a win
there's no there's no doubt
i was gonna say like with the with the
content space evolving always right um
let me let me explain to you what i do
yeah
please
everything that's happening now i was
talking about it 10 years ago i created
the weapons that everyone's trying to
use against me
that's why i created the weapons
so when they try to fight me i'm the one
that [ __ ] invented it can't beat me
now i started everything y'all doing
too funny to me
that was also an experiment
are you um
you know with the nft [ __ ] the metaverse
there's so much you know what it is what
your world means digitally is going to
mean more
than what your world means in the
physical
so think about what if you show up to a
[ __ ]
fashion show
in the [ __ ] uh
you know in the digital what do you call
that when you become met him no no
what you call it what you call those
no no a [ __ ] uh runway
no anyway what i'm saying is when you
come in as a
you know when they turn you into a i
know the name is a little drunk but when
they turn you into an avatar avatar
avatar when you're an avatar
number one what you're wearing as an
avatar
is going to be judged
your sneakers your clothes your car
where you live digitally
everything that you have digitally is
going to mean just as much it's
inevitable but at the same time it's
happening bro so no it's happening so
there's no there's no point in like
fighting it but at the same time why
would you fight it do you think much
freedom do you think do you think it's a
good thing though
every opportunity to get more money is
it a good thing it's a great thing if it
doesn't hurt anybody
do you think do you think it's a good
platform for artists nfts and for sure
change and the way to track it
all that [ __ ] is great
the way you resell it i'm just beautiful
it's a beautiful thing i feel like when
you make up your own money oh it's crazy
i'm saying the dollar means [ __ ] because
it does no gold to back it
and people caught on it they keep
printing money
and it's like
everybody there used to be the gold
standard everybody make you can make
your own coin and put an evaluation on
it but you just have to have people buy
into it
that's crazy
it's crazy man
you know i could create a coin in the
physical you can't get into this spot
unless you have it
you know
yeah no it's it's it's it's definitely
uh
i feel like we're gonna end up like
ready player one you saw ready player
one in the movie the steven spielberg
movie
it was a few years ago
steven spielberg made e.t right yes so
yeah you better watch what he [ __ ]
makes
it's crazy though i just don't know if
it's a good thing if we're all going to
be like that's fear everything is a good
thing
the people
this is just no such thing as ain't
going outside i don't want to say
something they're going to go outside in
the in the meadows
in this world in this universe in this
existence and any vibration there's a
yang in the yang there's just as much
negative as positive it's just
how you perceive it
everything has a negative there's a
negative in everything there's a
positive of it and everything
there's just some people focus only on
the negative that's called fear
you're leading with it
that's fair
it's the truth
if you lead with negative
then you're [ __ ] you lost
i everything is positive even when
something bad happens it must have
happened for a reason a good reason it's
just for me to find it
i'm not about how you approach why would
i pay attention to the negative or the
fear i can't control none of that [ __ ]
all i can control it's just like being
worried about who's the [ __ ]
president i don't care who's the
president i'm getting money we all
getting money yeah i tell that she's
people
versus universe whatever i'm still gonna
do what i'm gonna do i don't care yeah
that's that's some real [ __ ] so why i
feel that
if it's coming why fear it embrace it
monetize oh god that was crazy
big paws
big paws alerts
big paws alerts i got an interview on
that one
oh [ __ ]
hey uh somebody i want to talk to you
about who i feel like um
is someone else who i just feel like
doesn't get enough flowers as far as
being one of the greatest of all time is
beanie man
like we talked about the truth earlier i
think beanie siegel's like first four
albums are
just i mean man beans is
you know obviously
like i said i don't think he's
appreciated enough as an all-time great
in this rap game like
what was it like
early beanie siegel
prior to the truth dropping days like
it's a lot of going to court
that's why i called them state property
[ __ ] always had cases man
it's challenging you know you love
people that are in challenging
situations you know you still have to be
there for them regardless of whether it
makes you uncomfortable or not
it's a lot of things that were going on
that made me uncomfortable but i still
dealt with it
you know you don't
you don't leave the street to go back to
the street you know what i mean so it
was just like it was my responsibility i
had i signed on to that and i dealt with
it
and i protected everybody that was with
me but everyone that is with me is
legendary to me so you know
that's fair i said it's not about being
appreciated it's like a matter of when
this might not be his time to be
appreciated but he will at some point
um
you're 50 years old you've you've lived
an amazing life um
what would be
one or two lessons that you would just
want everyone to hear like that you had
that you lived for them like essentially
kind of give me give me you know we
talked about health we talked about fear
we talked about
you know what what are the life lessons
that you feel like you can offer the
world that that you live for them you
know what i'm saying at this point in
your life
worship women
that's that'll get you that's the best
that's the best advice the creator of
life should be worshiped
that's god right
as women
i i think that women should be looked at
like they're gods
i don't know why dudes want to be around
dudes all day
i don't get that
but women create life they nurture
you know
they don't lead with muscle they lead
with emotion and brain they have no
choice
they make us they have estrogen while we
make testosterone
well i'll be around a bunch of
testosterone and you got enough
i got enough nuts pours for me i don't
need any other nuts around me balls
you know what i mean
it makes sense to me it's logical i
don't get it i'd be like why the [ __ ]
would anybody want to roll with 10
[ __ ] and they could roll with 10
beautiful
and i'm not talking about aesthetically
i'm just talking about you know yeah
women are just [ __ ] dope i love women
man
i don't understand i'm like obsessed
i love women
uh the last thing man uh because i know
you gotta you gotta get get get to what
you gotta do tonight but yeah
you don't deserve a good woman unless
you're a good man
you don't deserve a queen unless you're
a kink hmm
you know what i mean you can't just be
like oh i'm gonna get a bad chick and
you you're a bum ass [ __ ]
if you go in dutch you're a bum ass
[ __ ]
i'm sorry say it one more time if you go
in dutch to me you're a bum ass [ __ ]
if you're letting your girl pay for
anything a girl you really care for
a gentleman just doesn't do that
you know what i mean yeah i don't care
so essentially
because i don't i don't our job is to
make it where a woman can do whatever
she wants she could raise
a child without any stress
supported
to create life
what else would a man want to do but
make that environment for any woman that
they care for
if you're not a man that makes your
woman's dream come true then you're not
her man
the person that makes you a woman's
dream come true
that's gonna be her man
and i'm the dream
[Music]
a
maker
a bar it's true
uh of course people uh could support man
you know obviously dame dash studios you
got the clothing i know you just had the
black friday sale um well you know i'm
launching
a a high-end designer line
you see those pictures on the wall oh i
see them yeah where'd you i made that
and i'm gonna launch it the way i'm
launching my clothing line is with a
movie
so all that you see is the clothing the
storyline
i see the storyboards yeah it's going to
be a movie and then it's going to be the
clothes that's how you're going to
launch the clothing line yeah how else
obviously
you've already done it once with
rockaway right
and state property and state property
people forget
shout out to state property i remember
being in junior high and going to
burlington coat factory and copping that
state property [ __ ] for real he was
copping at half price
at burlington i definitely was well you
know i was poor so we were at ross and
burlington so that was explaining to me
i just was telling you
yo that i'm i was scared it's okay it's
okay
why did how do clothes end up at
burlington code factory that's the whole
model bro
that's the whole model
just half price well all right let me
break it down i was breaking it down to
devin the other day
so ralph lauren right
[Music]
he creates a lifestyle
you know with all that other [ __ ] he
does purple label you don't make no
money from that i'm sorry i didn't hear
what you said ralph lauren ralph okay
yeah his real name is ralph lipschitz
should i call him off lipsticks comrade
flip shits so rough lip shits
this lipsticks guy right so what he does
is he creates this lifestyle
right and because he creates a lifestyle
a polo shirt costs five dollars to make
but the logo
just because that logo is on it he could
charge a hundred dollars
jc penney's or any other brand would
have to charge fifteen dollars
right that means wholesalers at seven
dollars
retailers are 15.
half price it says seven dollars
right
he puts it on there for a hundred
dollars
the half price is 50
and you think you're getting a deal but
he's still up and he's still up on the
margin so he makes all his money at the
outlets
and at all price
the problem with that business is you
have to do like 100 million and make
three million so you have to have like
four or five companies that you're just
pimping out
that make three million a piece so at
rachel roy i was making three million
dollars a year
from being a 100 million dollar company
and [ __ ] macy's the margins with
doo-doo
you know
so that's called the shimanta business
so yeah i mean obviously
uh it's all off price
to be
in like a regular store was just
marketing so that you could sell it at
burlington and all those off price
that's the whole game there it is that
makes sense if you could follow me then
it's a jewel i just dropped you could
wear it or i could take it back put it
on a shot you know
there it is so look so you so you're
you're saying the clothing line is
they're going to be when is that going
to launch
when the movie comes out
probably like march 5 i'm going to try
to catch a fast next fashion week or
whatever
i don't know i'm not on schedule you
know i don't know what day it is or what
time it is i'm just [ __ ]
having fun just having fun man
yeah
that's how we live bro we rock stars i
love it man hey thing about a rock star
is there's no fear with it you just
don't give a [ __ ]
and it's crazy when i see people that
project this rock star image and then
they're just scared all day
and not scared about violence but scared
about what people think
the minute you're worried about what
people think you've lost your robs your
rockstar
don't ever lose your rockstar bro
don't give a [ __ ]
go like this
that's don't give a [ __ ] repellent i
spray it on every day
you spray you should you should bottle
that up and sell it
damn no one will buy it i'd buy it
i know a lot of people that buy that
[ __ ] to be honest
there it is
no fear for you we out here now you're
not scared nothing you don't care about
what nobody thinks
i wanted to ask you i don't know if
you're comfortable talking about it on
camera but um
obviously
uh
also freshers contagious too
now you're gonna be fresh get him a ceo
package he won the cop
get that man right i need the shorts
that's okay i'm gonna buy a pair of
shirts i would give it to him but he
wants to support no yeah i support that
yeah i'm not going to stop him from
doing this
cash out a pair of those shorts those
shorts are fire you let them
but i would give them to me for free but
i respect no i would like to support man
we got to support man
come on man nah uh yo um
earlier we we had some some chocolate
some magic chocolates earlier uh i don't
know can we talk about those on the
podcast i just wanted to know like i
prefer not to until it's legal fair
enough all right we'll leave we'll leave
that conversation where where it where
where it is um but we booming
we are booming and uh
psychedelics are the future ladies and
gentlemen i would just like to point
that out and the present and the present
literally the present
for both of us at the moment
you know enjoy the president
do you ever like
think you know what i'm i'm really
thinking about doing dame is um
i'm thinking about going to costa rica
and doing the ayahuasca [ __ ]
have you heard of that i mean yeah i
just don't want no dude watching me
while i'm too [ __ ] high throwing up
and [ __ ]
yeah like you might throw up you might
shoot yourself and then there's just
some random i'm not doing nothing
there's just some random shaman that
you're just supposed to trust right
you're the most vulnerable moment of
your life and there's there's something
yeah oh i'm not doing it that's the
reason because girls like you should do
it i'd be like i ain't letting little
[ __ ] see me high and all crying and
[ __ ] yeah if i [ __ ] my pants in the
middle of the jungle that don't look
like something you want to
you guys want to see your girls want to
see you at that moment but yeah i think
i i just don't i just don't think my
brain is crazy because
when i do things like that my challenge
to me the fun part of it is acting
normal
so most people never know when i'm high
i'm high all the time
did you invent pause yes wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute i did not
know this i am the inventor you were the
inventor of pause my crew the best out
we invented pause for sure
just nobody could ever ever say that i
didn't no that's all of us that came
from my block
period my crew best out
what year was this how far are we going
about remember yeah when did the po are
we going like 80 obviously the 80s early
90s
[Music]
[ __ ] no
bugging that's when you found out about
it yeah it was a secret society
no one knew about paws for like 20 years
bro
and then all of a sudden i was like oh
[ __ ] me kids saying i'd be like you know
my son hits me with the pause at least
once a week yeah and also i invented i
made up the term fresh to death
i go say that listen i pop tags i made
that one up okay i i i'm the one that
named hover i made that up
i made that up
what was the inspiration for the hover
because jehovah you know
but but but pause we're gonna get back
to the pause because this is more the
more iconic cancelled
i understand that it's probably not the
most uh you know
it's not meant to be offensive it's
always been a personal joke with my
friends and now the whole world does it
it's like [ __ ] i can't even have a
[ __ ] personal joke you know
everyone's like people would ask me i'd
be like i would never tell them what it
meant ever i'd be like you have to
figure it out but no one knew what it
meant because if you say what it means i
think about this
just show a [ __ ] clip of me in the
history of any part of the world
at any time that i didn't say pause
were you saying pause
bro
don't understand
in harlem it don't matter how much money
you got
it don't matter what you're doing
if you slip [ __ ] are laughing
hard
if i do some dumb [ __ ]
it's like instagram they just i'm
because i'm so like
you know yeah so you catch me slipping
it's a celebration
like i don't even think i lost the snap
fight in like 100 years you know what
i'm saying can you remember one of the
more funniest like
moments in paw's history
yeah the one with you just now that was
one of the funniest ones because i feel
like maybe you have like a wrap like
maybe you're hanging out with bun b and
pimp c in 1998 and they don't know what
it is actually you killed it you got it
you won
you won like like somebody say yo what's
the i'm gonna say the time is there
thank you so pimsy pause
i wouldn't even correct him he was like
a g
i'm not saying like i would just listen
to him but he never would do no [ __ ]
like that i probably would say paul's
though but the one time i got to really
hang out with him was that big pimping
and we hung out me him and i feel like i
feel like there was a ugk song called
coming out hard that was just a possible
song title in general right the whole
conversation is a pause so let's go to
another one you know
i feel like that's the name of the ugk
zone coming out hard i think it could be
pause right yeah
i'm out of this conversation
great day man uh
obviously people can support what you're
doing um dame dash studios the app is
ill
you can check my [ __ ] on fox soul dame
dash take over i'm a television network
movie this dame dash distribution all i
said is on 2b i got new movies out that
i didn't make like once upon a time in
philly and social dilemma go to toby but
you could see on her up all that [ __ ]
the block is hot it's clicking if your
work is good come [ __ ] with me i'm a
[ __ ] full service movie studio
but weinstein was i am i'm the new guy
pause
bye
weinstein
me too
no no no no no you gotta say no me too
no me too no me too yeah no me too no me
too you gotta get his gate he's all
[ __ ] up now
he made history
wait a minute
you gotta add some context to that buddy
[ __ ]
you know what's gonna be funny when you
go back and boy's gonna be like nah you
[ __ ] up whatever
they're gonna be heating him up for a
while for that one
that's okay don't worry about it
i'd like to think i'd been saying pause
a long time not that one you said not
that that was the one time you should
have said it
if you've been playing it for 20 years
you should have not said that you said
fair enough that's fair now that i know
that you play the game oh it's even
funny oh god well i appreciate you damn
thank you for sitting down man i thank
you for coming through the environment
kicking in hope y'all get some b-roll
yeah and then we go i said it on tv you
gave me your word so we doing tv show we
gonna do it man but when we gonna do it
of course asap
tomorrow
let's meet let's go let's figure it out
man now we can make two more and we both
bosses we both want all our [ __ ] man
let's come together good come tomorrow
during the day and we could uh you know
i don't want everybody to know what time
we're gonna be here don't blow it up
bruh
you know what on camera you know
hey man shout out to my guy what's going
on
i appreciate you molly get in there go
in the camera yeah shout out to my guy
yo and you're in this hulk uh yeah get
in here
real quick sit down and plug your tick
tock and your drum [ __ ] and this is one
of the most legendary drummers in the
[ __ ] game
ask him why he don't go to instagram all
right
yeah talk about the con first of all you
have a trojan magnum tattoo listen
this guy's got a magnum condom tattoo on
his hand for life pause
that's possible yeah
yeah so yeah that's already i'm all i'm
already a troll anyway yeah yeah tag
your [ __ ] man
well i have no instagram so why not i
have no instagram because i put up a
post
about a lady in africa who
found out paws her husband was gay and
put
what is it super glue in the
ky jelly and you want to post it
wait wait wait wait
yeah so they deleted your instagram
because of that
that's what was my question because i it
wasn't like a thing i didn't show what
happened i just showed the news clip
from and that really happened and now it
happened in africa it happened in africa
it was news in africa that's [ __ ] up
yeah it is it's funny in africa
i follow some weird sites on ig i bet
you do
but i took the the video off of ig
though
pause go follow my guy
go follow me okay where can they follow
you at uh talk alien war tick-tock alien
war tick-tock on deck there it is my guy
there he is